[Música]
bueno
bajo
[Música]
hola
como tal
cómo está su actitud de hoy
vamos a ver bueno antes de primero
quiero decirles que es un verdadero
honor poder estar el día de hoy porque
al igual que ustedes he visto esta
charla cientos o miles de veces en la
televisión en internet y la verdad que
estar hoy aquí se siente bastante
importante también quiero confesarles
que me siento un poco nervioso a pesar
de que me dedico a esto me dedico a dar
conferencias pero nunca lo he hecho en
un rango de tiempo tan corto es más
difícil cómo tirarse un bong y digamos a
diferencia un paracaídas eso y además
que mi esposa está hoy aquí así que por
favor no me va a quedar mal
no quiere encargar un divorcio en sus
conciencias
para colmo también están mis
instructores del gimnasio o la doble
presión alguien más conocido
solamente iba a pedir dos cosas su mente
muy abierta o mejor dicho intenté vaciar
la en estos próximos minutos y luego
recuerden llenarla nuevamente sino no va
a funcionar su vida
y segundo intenten ver esto como una
oportunidad nueva de creación
profesional para cada uno de ustedes
aunque en este momento no lo sepan al
rato van a saber por qué hoy se cumplen
dos años desde que casualmente el mundo
de los spurs o deportes electrónicos me
cautivó y realmente me cautivó como pasa
normalmente en este tipo de cosas lo
tome con mucho escepticismo seguramente
como lo están tomando en este momento y
un poco la idea el día de hoy es poder
desarrollar temas de manera coherente
para que entiendan cuál es la naturaleza
y este fenómeno mundial me sentía así
como la foto estaba como una cápsula
criogénica me despertaron y de repente
el mundo había cambiado muchísimo y yo
me considero una persona con un carácter
innovador bastante importante siempre
voy en búsqueda de negocios que tengan
este valor de disrupción pero esto
realmente como idea me superó yo no
podía creer que había personas en el
mundo que estuviesen dedicándose a esto
y después de mostrar algunos datos como
lo que vamos a ver a continuación
es importante que veamos el potencial de
la audiencia actualmente se espera que
los próximos cuatro años la audiencia
total de los deportes electrónicos
alcancen los 860 millones de personas
esto para en la escala mundial estamos
pensando que es una de cada diez
personas en el mundo y voy a aprovechar
este escenario intentar romper un poco
el protocolo de la de la conversación
solamente para hacer una pequeña
encuesta porque es importante también
poder que me puedan llevar información
levanten la mano
honestamente quienes ustedes juegan los
videojuegos actualmente aunque sí si
quieren volver a ver lo bastante
importante el número probablemente 60 70
por ciento de la audiencia quienes nunca
han tenido contacto con un videojuego
nunca
ni el space este cuando se va al
internet
esto también cuenta
bueno realmente el impacto que tiene es
bastante importante quiero mostrarles un
poco una de las preguntas que a mí me
llenó el espíritu en el buen sentido de
la palabra porque la pregunta que me
dice ok
podemos ganar dinero jugando videojuegos
es decir puedo ser incluso
suficientemente hábil desarrollar estas
habilidades para poder ganar dinero y
resulta que por ejemplo en la liga
norteamericana the league of legends
actualmente este año particularmente en
julio instituyó un salario mínimo para
jugadores principiantes es decir si tú
eres un novato dentro de la liga
profesional tienes un salario mínimo de
75 mil dólares anuales
bastante importante y creo que con esto
veamos que esto es simplemente el inicio
jugadores soy la liga profesional que
gana 10 11 o 20 veces más que este
dinero incluso mucho más
y había que avanzando en información me
daba cuenta de que tenía que empezar a
pensar una manera distinta y esto es
porque realmente lo que pasó en mi vida
fue que una persona se acercó y me
ofreció una oportunidad de negocios
levanten la mano a quien de sueño de
empresa
ok poquito es que está pasando con la
imprenta del mismo
imagínate que alguien te dice sabes que
vamos a invertir dinero en una empresa
de esports y en este momento como te
resulta completamente ajeno te digo más
tiene que invertir 100 mil dólares que
me dices
hamas un poco la idea fuerza cuando se
me acerca a mí con esta idea por
supuesto no fue la cantidad que me
pidieron les pido por favor no me
quieren raptar cuando termine esto fue
mucho menos la cantidad pero al final
del día es una oportunidad de negocios
cuando llego a mí realmente la sensación
fue o que necesito tener más información
porque realmente no lograba entender la
dimensión hasta que obviamente los
números se empezaron a acercar a mí pero
uno de los paradigmas que tenemos que
romper o se tiene que romper y no en el
mundo particularmente en latinoamérica y
en mexico es que debe ser un deporte
nacional tiene que ser un deporte
olímpico y les voy a explicar por qué
las organizaciones hoy como la nuestra
de deep y fai que me está sufriendo
muchísimo porque a la hora de importar
jugadores resulta muy complicado por su
situación migratoria tiene sentido
verdad es decir no podemos traer
jugadores porque no podemos generar un
compromiso legal en el país
esto significa que simplemente vienen
como turistas pero ustedes ofrecen la
admiración en mexico y si no yo les
comento que es bastante estricta
y en ese sentido si las cosas no
funcionan se deporta imaginen ahora cómo
te sentirías tú siendo jugador
profesional no poder asistir a un país
como méxico para poder cumplir tu sueño
hizo un poco la situación en la que
estamos hoy así que uno de los
paradigmas que debe romperse es esta
burbuja tiene que estallar finalmente en
un tema legal como aparecía en el vídeo
y con muchos países en el mundo hoy
estado aportando
hay un tema millonario espíritu cuando
lo escuché y recuerden que lo que estoy
intentando hacer es poder traer a
ustedes información así como yo la
recibí bueno yo me enteré que en méxico
y en el mundo hay universidades que
están entregando becas completas para
aquellos profesionales que quieren jugar
a sus equipos realmente me pareció
todavía un proceso mucho más motivador
porque todavía fortalece mucho más la
idea de poder incluso romper con un mito
que en realidad se invitó hoy pero
cuando ustedes han escuchado es que se
la pasan jugando están todo el día
jugando videojuegos cierto y la realidad
es que eso hoy a medida que estas
habilidades se van desarrollando puede
traer frutos como por ejemplo una beca
universitaria en una de las mejores
universidades del mundo es importante
ver que el fenómeno se va desarrollando
de una manera bastante importante esta
gráfica realmente lo que muestra son las
universidades en eeuu que han empezado a
adoptar este sistema de beca para
aquellas personas que quieren emprender
los deportes electrónicos como
organización o como jugadores
profesionales y tienen si apenas en el
año 2014 solamente había una universidad
de eeuu y hoy en el presente año tenemos
ya 60 cuantas universidades en méxico
creen ustedes que tienen que han
adoptado este sistema
es interactuar más fácil lo que ponga
mal con la esposa
o que están en tres en web en lo que
sigue escuchando que está entre 0 y 5 y
si realmente está así apenas dos
universidades en méxico han adoptado
esto y ninguna necesariamente famosa
se dan cuenta el rezago que existe entre
el comportamiento humano el avance
tecnológico y particularmente lo que
pasa a latinoamérica proporciona esto
estamos dejando ir oportunidades
increíbles como será por ejemplo en
méxico existen organizaciones y
latinoamérica amateurs
que paga incluso hasta 20 mil pesos
mensuales como en el caso de mi
organización a jugadores amateurs para
que estén dentro de los equipos y puedan
competir en instancias regionales
nacionales e internacionales todos
tienen hijos
todos son hijos seguramente imagínate
que ahora tu papá dice a que te vas a
dedicar la mente muy dedicar a jugar
videojuegos cuál sería su reacción
muy mal lo mismo que yo pensé y sintió
no y centrado en este fondo seguramente
estaría pensando lo mismo sin embargo 20
mil pesos por mes está bastante bien
para un chico de 18 años cierto y lo que
está haciendo es una integración de su
formación no crean que lo que único que
hace están jugando videojuegos esta
persona como
sí
voy a poner un módulo al final
fíjense una persona que está dentro de
este programa de profesionalización del
deporte electrónico no solamente se la
pasa jugando es como cualquier deporte
es una disciplina de tal hora tal hora
entrena también se entrena en un tema
aspecto físico porque evidentemente el
desgaste mental que existe es bastante
fuerte y al mismo tiempo hay una
formación integral como en el caso de
las universidades y por supuesto
programas académicos pero tiene que
vamos más lejos hoy existe una maestría
en la universidad internacional de
valencia en gestión de deportes
electrónicos
cuánto tiempo más va a pasar para que
empecemos a adoptar nuevas ideas y
tendencias el fenómeno es muy grande
quiénes son los que más se sienten
atraídos de tener 858 millones de
usuarios al pendiente de esto
las marcas cierto con una audiencia tan
grande mucho más grande que el superbowl
mucho más grande que lo que pueda pasar
una final del mundo los que más sienten
atraídos en la industria evidentemente
el entretenimiento
quiero mostrarles cómo se ve por ejemplo
en la luz y hay universidad de
california irvine como las instalaciones
por ejemplo de parte de lo que es el
proceso de integración de deportes
electrónicos evidentemente es un espacio
donde una persona puede no ser renta por
supuesto simplemente es como como si
fuera hasta la biblioteca o no sé para
el espacio por un tiempo pero al final
del día hay módulos en los que hay
equipos profesionales en este momento
entrenando y por supuesto espectadores
la verdad que el espacio todavía es
mucho más grande demasiadas imágenes
pero es mucho más intenso bueno otro
ámbito que hay me entusiasmó mucho rompe
es como luce un jugador de deportes
electrónicos actualmente profesionales
porque hasta hace un tiempo seguramente
unos minutos para ustedes estaban
imaginando con todo respeto un grupo de
pequeños coreanos todos encerrados en un
cuarto jugando
existe de todo como en cualquier deporte
hay personas diferentes complexión
física intelectual y demás aquí el punto
es que es muy atractivo hoy para el
industria entretenimiento y los deportes
particularmente patrocinadores el look
de un jugador profesional estamos de
acuerdo este es el caso por supuesto el
de su izquierda de martín larsson es un
jugador sueco es un gran jugador no es
uno de los mejores jugadores en el mundo
d league of legends tiene apenas 22 años
tremenda educación es muy carismático y
por la misma razón evidentemente genera
una aceptación mucho más importante para
marcas y por supuesto para su equipo que
es fanática es uno de los equipos más
importantes de esta disciplina en el
mundo ha sido campeón del mundo etcétera
y del lado derecho cristiano ronaldo
que es el segundo mejor jugador del
mundo
y porque es el segundo porque y charla y
yo digo lo que quiera
de cuántas maneras podemos ganar dinero
tengo que ser un jugador profesional
para ganar dinero en este mundo no
necesariamente puede ser un jugador
amateur como lo que acabo de mencionar
mi organización también alberga
jugadores amateurs y ganan en promedio
entre 15 y 20 mil pesos por mes sin
embargo hay plataformas como la de tuits
que nos otra cosa más que una página web
para poder compartir material
videográfico por supuesto y material en
línea de lo que uno hace es decir si
estás filmando en todo momento cómo
estoy jugando entonces hay una persona
que está jugando está transmitiendo en
vivo y está ganando dinero
[Música]
envidiable imagínense estar jugando
estoy jugando y empieza entrar dinero y
empieza otro dinero y empieza a tener
dinero como intra dinero de tres maneras
la primera es no es la primera
necesariamente pero este orden a través
de donaciones es decir yo estoy jugando
puedo generar un público de seguidores
como el de ustedes que les interesa mi
contenido dentro de mi canal y usted
están haciendo aportaciones a través de
paypal su tarjeta de crédito demás
así que si tienen hijos cuidado con este
tema
no porque está recibiendo dinero sino
porque pueden estar pagar
y esos mayores que hagan lo que quieran
esas donaciones van desde un dólar hasta
casos que han les han donado en una
fracción de segundo diez mil dólares y
los invito a ver vídeos en youtube de
las reacciones de estos streamers cuando
reciben esas cantidades imagínense que
usted están jugando de reflector cerca
de diez mil dólares
la alegría de muchos w enseñar cómo
funciona esto
otra forma de ganar dinero es siendo
partner de tweets es decir si tú es
considera que tú eres una persona que
periódicamente está generando contenido
en tu canal tienes un grupo de
seguidores de más de 500 y estás
generando mínimo 3 strings por semana
500 simultáneamente los seguidores las
quinientas personas viendo en ese
momento el canal lo que va a ser twitch
es dividir las ganancias de patrocinios
porque imagínense que hay canales que lo
ven miles de personas quienes pueden
estar interesados en esas miles de
personas evidentemente las marcas de
periféricos de videojuegos teclados y
demás y lo que hace básicamente estas
marcas es pagar por un espacio
publicitario y lo que hace tweets es
dividir las ganancias 50 y 50 50 para la
persona que es dueña del canal y 50 para
la empresa
interesante otra manera de ganar dinero
es que hay empresas que te entregan
links para que tú lo que ustedes y de
esa manera cuando alguien quiere comprar
un por ejemplo un videojuego lo que hace
generar una comisión directa por venta
por lo tanto ganar dinero de múltiples
maneras pero de tres maneras muy
importantes es decir que un jugador
profesional aparte de recibir su salario
mientras está entrenando individualmente
dentro de su espacio su ley mi house
está ganando dinero de muchas maneras
hay distribuyan que ganan cien mil
doscientos mil dólares por mes
y obviamente está de más decir que viven
de eso pero lo hacen de una manera
bastante importante con un tiempo muy
reducido trabajando cuatro o cinco horas
al día todo el que trabaja más de día
estamos pensando evidentemente la
envidia
también quiero mostrarles que hay
personalidades en el mundo del
entretenimiento y los deportes como la
leyenda que estamos viendo en este
momento el mejor jugador de todos los
tiempos michael jordan actualmente en
este año en marzo de este año hizo una
inversión de 26 millones de dólares en
un equipo que ya existe que es un equipo
llamativo liquid es un equipo
profesional
pero así como él como vio en el vídeo
hay muchísimas personalidades en el caso
de rick fox por ejemplo que lo mostraba
había jugado también los ángeles lakers
el ex propietario de echo fox que su
propio equipo y este equipo este año
recibió por patrocinios solamente 42
millones de dólares que a su vez también
les sirvió para comprar a uno de los
mejores jugadores del mundo que llama
junín es un coreano
otro monstruo que ha invertido en este
negocio y ha invertido por dos razones
muy específicas la promoción específica
para poder llevar a los juegos olímpicos
en el 2028 y para poder hacer el mundial
de deportes electrónicos y están ellos
en una inversión de casi 150 millones de
dólares y están esperando recibir de
ganancias junto con un patrón paquete de
patrocinio entre 4.500 y 5.000 millones
de dólares para el 2020
interesante no escucharon bien 5000
millones de dólares
qué es esto
[Música]
un bar pero como sería es un sport bar
es un y sports bar y realmente funciona
exactamente igual que cualquier bar
simplemente que en vez de estar pasando
deportes ordinarios como son básquetbol
fútbol y demás estamos pasando deportes
electrónicos
quise mostrarles esta foto para resumir
en gran parte el potencial de este
negocio este es un negocio que crece a
una tasa del 30% anual y todos aquí que
estamos en los negocios saben que un
negocio que crece a esa tasa mundial y
que tiene ingresos de más de 1000
millones dólares por año es un gran
negocio imagínense todo lo que se mueve
alrededor de este negocio que se
necesita mucha imaginación un buen plan
de negocios y capital por supuesto
bueno quiero mostrarles un poco un poco
de mi organización es una organización
como cualquier otra que van a estar
escuchando en los próximos días porque
seguramente el tema le va a interesar
suficiente para investigar
hemos estado en instancias competitivas
de manera presencial les muestra una
foto cuando viajamos obviamente nuestra
ropa deportiva quiero mostrarles dos
cosas la primera vez
un vídeo que hizo uno de nuestros
jugadores es uno de nuestros jugadores
más entusiastas nuestra organización se
divide en tres partes en tres países
república dominicana colombia y mexico
el problema de méxico aparte de la
situación migratoria que les acabo de
decir es que provocó que toda la
inversión
eventos presenciales que ya existían en
la república mexicana y que hablar gas
diferentes deportes electrónicos se
fugaran a colombia perú argentina y
venezuela
si venezuela bien
entonces justo lo hizo en un marco de
deterioro importante justo cuando la
empresa movistar había decidido invertir
en latinoamérica 500 millones de dólares
básicamente en méxico vacío toda esta
condición de oportunidad de negocio así
de oportuno
a este son algunos de los imágenes un
grupo de nuestros jugadores aquí en
méxico en república dominicana colombia
y quiero mostrar es un vídeo un
fragmento de vídeo muy breve para que
vean cómo se vive internamente dentro de
nuestra organización que te puedo decir
seguramente que me gusta la adrenalina
que se siente cuando estás ganando
no no no
[Música]
no mi amor
no siempre se gana lo importante es que
este alumnado con tornillos
[Música]
ah
ay me llena de emoción saber que hay
chicos que están generando este tipo de
contenidos y que es parte de su sueño
pertenecer a esta gran disciplina
realmente hoy quise mostrarles el
potencial que tiene uno de los negocios
más disruptivos en la última década los
negocios los deportes electrónicos
yo quisiera pedirles un favor entonces
que este proceso de pocos minutos no
necesariamente nos lleva a la
profundidad del tema pero quiero que con
toda esta evidencia ustedes puedan
pensar en los próximos meses y si alguna
vez alguna persona se les acerca y les
dice quiero dedicarme a esto piensen que
existe un gran potencial de desarrollo
profesional integral y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]